Welcome to the class of 2022.
To start our online kickoff,
I thought I'd take you outside for
a quick tour of some of my
favorite places at Stanford.
Let's start at Coupa.
You'll quickly discover that
there are several Coupa cafes on
the Stanford campus.
The GSB one is the best.
It's the center of activity on campus and
Dean Lowery's unofficial office.
Last week,
I was trying to keep a low profile.
But I had a chance meeting with a few
earlier rivals from your class.
That made my day.
[MUSIC]
Town Square is the heart of the GSB,
the tents and
the outer furniture are recent additions.
Phil Knights footsteps are a reminder
of the people who've come before you
at the GSB and whose shoes you're filling.
When the Knight Management Center
was built,
the artists Peter Wagner
design the cornerstone.
He perfectly captured the GSB,
dedicated to
the things that haven't happened yet and
the people who are about to dream them up.
I first came to Stanford as
an undergraduate in 1990 and
joined the faculty ten years later.
I'm still amazed by
the beauty of the campus.
The Rodin Sculpture Garden is one of
the famous places on the Stanford campus.
And for those of you with children,
it's one of the few museums
that our kids actually enjoy.
Some people think the Coupa Cafe in your
Green library is as good as the one at
the GSB mistakenly.
[MUSIC]
I hope you all will make an effort to
experience Stanford beyond the GSB and
to meet the brilliant students and
faculty in Law, Medicine, Engineering,
Education, Sustainability and
other fields.
I promise it will inspire you.
Of course, the physical campus is one
part of what makes Stanford special, but
it's not the important part.
It's the people you will meet and
the relationships you'll form that will
truly make your time here memorable.
So again, welcome to the GSB.
We can't wait to see what you dream up.